sometimes in politics something or
someone we think we know can reinvent
can become something brand new look
beyond the old pinstripe suit the
obligatory pint in hand because behind
the trappings of the familiar
there is something stirring in British
politics something we've never seen
before this is the story of an old face
fronting a new party with a fresh
language and a radical message assault
on everything we've known in British
political life and how its Estonians
have allowed to do
[Applause]
the nose to the left 432 from maze first
Commons defeat in January day by day
Westminster our political institutions
and our main parties became gripped and
tainted by ever greater indecision Oh as
the public's frustration grew it became
obvious to me that a new force remain or
leave could use the now inevitable
European elections to break through one
man had already been working on it for
some time please welcome to the stage
Nigel fer arch without anyone noticing
Nigel Faraj spent the dying months of
2018 quietly building up a network an
organization South by his friend and now
brexit Party Chairman multi-millionaire
Richard theis leave means leave
collecting name supporters experimenting
with social media strategy and
grassroots organizing
that embryonic organization became the
brexit party I've been following them
from their first rally to the last talk
to its leaders and witnessed the genesis
of a force which in only six weeks of
campaigning is changing the contours of
British politics when I arrived in
Birmingham as struck most by the
comparison to the amateurishly please
leave this was an organization much
changed to branding the logo the
professionalism of it all had
transformed and that's before we even
reach the message itself no mention of
immigration
none of the familiar tropes of Health
and Safety or bendy bananas instead
again and again like a laser beam that
this country this once great country has
been shamed by those who govern us sign
through the House of Commons is such a
shameful document it could only ever
have been signed by somebody who had
been defeated in war it is a travesty
I think the argument that we are one of
the oldest functioning democracies in
the world that has seen democracy
produced by our career politicians over
the last couple of years is a very
powerful argument the Westminster
commentary at and political set perhaps
underestimate the underlying level of
support I've generally genuinely got out
there across the country what does that
be like the trial was it Nigel came
around fighting back and he spread it
back so much having a principle that's
village baby
2005 and there were about those people
and you know you could just fill in the
room is electric and it isn't just about
it's about its or the translation
importance and it's
allow him to effectively become the
change candidate not just a brick see
before politics jealousy top story a
disappointing night for both main
parties in the local elections the
Conservatives have lost over 900 seats
so far and the Prime Minister admits a
party took a beating in many walks of
life the business be it be it be a
culture a bit political campaigning
America is always a few years ahead of
us and I have spent a fair bit of time
in America I've learned one or two
things that were just that politics
needs to be a bit less drab a bit less
dull it needs to be lively fun energy
and that's what we're trying to do here
you've got people like them with huge
like standing information by the crowd
I'm gonna get another pair Oh Lord it is
the kind of heroes of the English those
patronizing nincompoop say during their
dinner parties oh poor things they
didn't know what they were voting for
that was what we were waiting for a
sovereign state what's wrong with a good
old-fashioned British compromise
something that will bring two sides
together what if it could be shown just
bear with me
what is it could be shown that we would
definitely lose jobs and if we came out
with a hard break search so what we'd
get over it
we'd get over it so it'd be worth anyway
whatever yeah what do you think of
Jeremy Corbyn
[Applause]
how will you feel if Theresa May and
Jeremy Corbyn put a deal together in the
next few weeks the usual political
stitcher it's not one person in this
audience would want us to be a victim of
this complete surrender it's a document
in sanik it's surrendered in a war
none of us Sky News star you
why shame on me what I done to you thank
you I'm a reporter yeah but like what
what do we say that's fake but most of
it I'm never been to a dog Trump rally
by reckon it's probably not a million
miles away from them just as the anger
and the bitterness and I just think the
idea that if cool bit of may put the
deal together that I know a bit this is
gonna go away it's for the birds it's
for the birds might not come back an
effect may but because should we go up
but Corbin be a nightmare whoever takes
over from they'll be a nightmare it's
just not gonna go away that angers not
real subscribe the brexit party out of
nowhere has overtaken the Tories in the
polls but they think labour voters hold
Jeremy Corbyn and his party just as
culpable for the paralysis in
Westminster and their vote is soft do
you think he understands people like you
places like pontiff work better than the
Labour Party hopefully well labour don't
give her to Lucas
they don't care there's things happening
and they're not bothered of course
affect Cooper's been one of the leading
remainders in Parliament waste it's a
freighter everything a traitor to the
world into walls to everybody even they
said everyone will make that
[Applause]
[Music]
it's just a message from the month of
our song tonight Oh Oh mr. Faraj gutted
that I can't come today
quoted their page oh and I also told my
brother today
that Nigel flag is there what time I
love that guy in this campaign Faraj has
set the turns
here's equates himself and his cause
with country his vision is to believe in
barrettes it is to believe in Britain
and so the pure of the brexit the pure
your love of Britain that we are as
powerful if not more powerful in the EU
and if that's your view there any
compromise with them is by definition
[Applause]
because even though they've got 15
trillion dollar economy we've got to so
end of the day another 650 people on top
of the early they were the Pharaohs
we've got Riley after a rally after a
rally right up until election bags put
in the hard yards and I think it's
better to say more than any other party
and I just can't believe it really in a
sense that as far as sense to me
he said it in there one set on camera
but he said to me he can't believe his
luck I can't believe his luck because
the two main party leaders to reason may
enjoy a record we'd have just left the
battlefield open for him and I did that
for two weeks and as a result that space
that's faced with normally in any
national election the main party leaders
would fill he's filled and now there's
pobably no stopping so I had planned
hopes to be in Melanson for another
rally today but syriza may I sort of
like well inconvenience things a little
bit by housing that she's not gonna be
around
stay here but unfortunately I can be
there without actually being there
because they have a pretty stellar
unusually stellar social media presence
good evening prime minister when are we
going who knows every party rally is
streamed to thousands of people on
Facebook and Twitter as the campaign has
progressed the numbers have swelled
supporters interact and coordinate
activity I can imagine mr. Churchill
walking down the halls of Westminster
with his cane and cigar smoke coming
into this room standing for the brexit
party and then saying what are you doing
to my party the Tory party and whack
them around their head Britain is a
nation of sleeping lines best not to
wake them up well guess what as the
campaign climaxes Farraj dominates its
closing days he is struck with a
milkshake he's still loathed by many far
from brushing off the incident with the
milkshake he furiously accuses
remainders of the radicalization of
politics I think we can all agree that
politics has become coarser in recent
years but I put it to you look do you
think that maybe you are partly
responsible for that cause I mean just a
few things that you said in recent class
you said that if you can get this little
bricks that you want your dong cocky
pick up a rifle in front that was a
metaphor joke okay let me excuse me said
during a comedy he okay well I scribe
you described the British negotiating
team as the enemy within
you've said many times in this campaign
that Mays deal could only have been
signed by a nation defeated in war
absolutely you consistently invoke the
language of war of appeasement treachery
anyone who doesn't agree
here's the word treachery betrayal a
sure okay betrayal but I've been up many
of your others as you know very often
when you mentioned people like Jeremy
Corbyn not to read them out and a Subaru
or wherever it is you mentioned their
names you get the crowd to boot okay
fair enough quite pan so but fair enough
and then people shout out things like
traitor now you never turn around to
them and say no excuse me sir madam
they're not traitors they're citizens
they're Patriots I just disagree with
them I'm sorry I'm sorry
history teacher something here if you
tell people they are superior or they're
the user superior to another group of
people
bad things happen the only way the only
way that civilized democracy functions
is if the loser consents to the result
and what you've had here since the
referendum has some very senior public
figures who do not accept the will of
the people and that has radicalized
Brutus charging at you in this campaign
is that you know it's not that easy to
lose you know full well oh no it isn't
this point and M respond you know full
well that we've been in this
organization for 45 years
it is permeated every aspect of our
lives we are in one single economic area
with the European Union the reason that
it's not easy to leave is because you
will write that it was a very powerful
dominant force in our life and other
people like Teresa Mary and Jeremy
Corbyn or whoever they have got to try
and take us out with care because it was
so dominant and then you come along and
say no it's easy I think you know it's
not easy we have but you we are now god
we have now drawn people didn't it we've
never a deadline of the 31st of October
all right that date will build up in the
minds of the British people in the same
whether 29th of March did we have gone
many many months now to build on the
work that was already done to be fair
the European Union have done even more
work on the WTO brexit the we've done
this is not a difficult thing to do but
to do it you have to believe in it and
what is clear is that misses may never
believe
it is by far the most ambitious thing
I've ever done
we are attempting a peaceful political
revolution in this country it is needed
it is needed it is needed anyone he's a
really one that he's made the party the
thing which is new about the rekted
party isn't it's your skepticism instead
it is its attitude to politics
it represents a full-on assault on every
British political institution the
parties the media the court
parliamentary democracy itself a system
in which people have lost trust and
without that this party could not exist
we thought the referendum with Britain's
great populist revolt it may have been
but mere prologue
[Applause]
[Applause]